well we had one former champ in the seat
just now and we have another former
champion as well
sabina uh welcome to the show
your position
according to nazi she felt like maybe d5
was
not
the best move maybe you felt
uncomfortable can you give us your
reasoning behind the move yeah i mean i
was uh definitely not expected
to play against e4 today because okay
she hasn't played in three years but
uh you know you're usually playing your
stuff and if our first move was
certainly something that surprised me
from move one and i was like okay i'm
gonna surprise you too so i'll play
sicilian
and then um i know these types of
positions black if black doesn't play d5
i think the position is a little bit
uncomfortable because there's bishop g5
coming in and then i was considering h6
so bishop g5 take the knight and then
the outpost of course
um okay all right and so that's why i
thought okay uh i'm going to play um
d5 you said you were going to play six i
was going to but i didn't like it so
much because of maybe g4 i thought at
some point she will start attacking me
and still maybe first
yeah maybe she can first yes double up
the rooks make sure d5 is not an option
because that's a really important thing
for black to do with the bishop in e7 so
i figured if i don't play now d5
probably my dad would
say something when i go back home
because
he told me he told me before this
tournament he was sabina be careful play
positional chess don't go crazy and and
i was like okay this is both i'm doing
both so hopefully he's okay with that d5
and after that like i know i'm staying
with the pawn down but
i feel that it's not so easy for white
to improve
the position because both uh d5 and
f5 pawns are are um weak and she had a
chance at some point to play g4 i
actually was surprised she didn't play
she let me play h5 and after that i felt
that
i'm okay i have a pawn down but i think
i have compensation i may be wrong i
don't know what the engine said but as i
was playing i thought okay i'm gonna
you know be pretty safe i think you
evaluated pretty well according to what
the engine said if i remember correctly
and you managed to get the draw with
some some good play here
uh you have won this tournament before
your aspirations coming in
for this event
well
i know i wanted before but it was under
some
i had uh you know a hard time and then
it turned out to be
a surprising event so
uh
you know i haven't played so much during
the pandemic playing online is not
really my strong
thing i don't enjoy it as much as
playing over the board so
i just want to play good games you know
just
kind of
remember why i enjoy playing chess so
that's that's my goal i don't have a
goal to win or anything like that i
heard actually what nazi said earlier
but i don't have that goal i just want
to play good chess that's i think it's
the most important all right well we
look forward to seeing more good games
from you good luck thank you so much
absolutely good luck uh